Omar Villafranca is in the Crescent City
with a part of that story
Omar good morning good morning we are
here on the south shore of Lake
Pontchartrain the West End area the wind
is starting to pick up over here we're
in between rain right now the rain bands
are to our East in the mobile area but
people here are still getting ready and
people in New Orleans are breathing a
sigh of relief because the Mississippi
River is expected to crest at about 17
feet not the originally predicted 19
feet and keep in mind the barriers all
around the cities the levees are
anywhere from 20 to 25 feet
officials expect those to do their job
but still people here in New Orleans
have learned their lesson so people and
businesses are doing everything they can
to prepare for whatever Mother Nature
throws their way ray Peter says he and
his family are preparing for the worst
we spoke to him as he loaded several
sandbags into his pickup to place around
his New Orleans home Peters was not
alone he is one of many locals who
survived Hurricane Katrina though
forecasters say it is unlikely Barry
will become a ferocious hurricane no one
is taking any chances for Katrina red 24
the water here
yeah 23 feet of water for Katrina yeah
you learn that lesson no mandatory
evacuations were ordered in New Orleans
officials instead urged residents to
shelter in place while tourists have
been instructed to take shelter in
hotels many businesses in the city's
popular French Quarter are boarded up
and closed rolling stones lead singer
Mick Jagger tweeted that the band will
be spending the weekend in the city
after their Sunday night's show at the
Superdome was pushed to Monday the flood
protection Authority shared this video
of sandbags prepared in the facility for
flooding throughout the weekend
Louisiana Governor John bel Edwards says
officials are preparing for a major rain
event across much of the state it is
noteworthy that we are in our 260th day
of a flood fight on the Mississippi
River the longest in history and that
this is the first time in history a
hurricane
will strike the state of Louisiana while
the Mississippi River has been a flood
station the roads here in New Orleans
are pretty clear there was no major rain
overnight so they're really lucky for
that but officials are warning people to
not let their guard down because the
rain is coming we're just going to wait
a little bit longer Dana yeah Omar
obviously wise advice and also no matter
how much as you mentioned they're
already rain soaked